the mystery that surrounds us is so
profound ninety to ninety eight percent
that that eight percent differs from
thing you read to then you read this
dark energy or dark matter we don't know
what it is we don't know what ninety
eight percent of the universe is and
this wonderful man Einstein this
wonderful man who imagined these
scientific theories much like the Greeks
who said all right if you cut something
in half you got a have you cut that half
and you keep going down the line you
must come to the end and they said we'll
call it an atom and that's how they made
their scientific discoveries through the
logic of imagination whereas we have
tools to dimly dimly see into the
physical nature dimly see a law yeah
that seems to be a law wait a minute
there's something here that counteracts
that law so just like our diets the
pyramid carbohydrates a little bit of
meat one day is a hundred and eighty
degrees reverse no no no what we meant
was protein and a little bit of
carbohydrates exactly 180 degrees
different in your diet that's what's
happening in science all the time
there's a wonderful line science
scientists spread rumors we know
everything is unified we know if we use
our imagination like the Greeks we look
around us and we say the whole world is
unified electrically atoms thing matter
there's got to be a operating the thing
that's to be managed in some way it's
there everything follows a logic we had
these little instruments
peer into the universe we're seeing a
speck we're seeing a dust mote wouldn't
the theory of everything
maybe you discover that as you die maybe
as you die you go there's the theory of
everything boom and you're dead